awful like the worst
horrible year i've probably ever had it
was tough like
you cannot underestimate how tough that
first year is
and i went into recruitment at 24 so
for me it was like make or break this
isn't just an opportunity to give
something a go
it's either going to work or it's not oh
bloody ham don't give up until the rolls
are filled but when i say
blood sweat and tears went into that
this business i am not lying like the
amount of graft that went in
we started at eight o'clock swept out a
few candidates this morning i had a
bd call booked in with a client actually
this morning the meeting
had a catch-up with a couple of members
of my team about bottlenecks and how
they're getting on
then i had an interview for someone at
transition partners and
then i hosted this event and then now
i've come on your podcast so in terms of
bd time
it's been fairly limited but the
conversations i've had have been i've
been the right
conversations i do a lot of initiatives
within women in tech
and i think it's about exploring
opportunities and
i guess it's just using the same the
same principles and apply it to
recruitment
telling people about the opportunity if
i speak to young people and they don't
know what they want to do and i think
they've got the right characteristics to
make them a good recruiter
i will tell them that they should give
recruitment a go because what six months
eight months in recruitment it could
completely change their life and it did
mine
[Music]